I guess I don't
know especially all those
first all the
boun let me know when you're ready ready
ready ready ready all
right all right Chris this was uh this
is flame Festival 2015 or no flame
Festival
1997 uh this was spinning three dampo at
the same damn time like Advanced
three-point we went over using the
bounce on the one side uh simil to a
Superman moving it from the outside of
our body stepping out hitting the inside
of the opposite leg so either outside of
Nate or sorry outside of non-native side
or inside of native
side you can also with your non-native
foot step behind your native foot and
use the shin of the leg that step behind
so I can go outside inside
Shin you move any combination of these
yeah um we did the same flipped
thing oh sorry not the same one side
bounce thing but flip Superman and only
bouncing behind
us we did all of these bounce things
with an
extension inside outside leg cross
we switch between
trra and the
extension same thing behind the
back oh
sorry we had 3 beat Superman or I guess
flipping
Superman with the two beat weed
got it with extension see which makes
this
weird
like there a strange
butterfly pattern right there once the
pinky side's going
up uh we went over the different styles
of juggling either with
pendulum or with the
spin I also went over wall plane
juggling uh we juggled po without
throwing by doing dangle
Cascade and what this is is this grip I
think it's Tim God grip thumb index
index as we turn our hand setting the
twoo index finger into our thumb side
then sliding the one po down to our
index same thing going back you're
Notting
itting start speeding it
up dangle
Cascade every time you set the index poy
of the meteor
hand or the two boy hand whatever every
time I'm setting into my thumb grip that
poy can bounce on my
body by leaning back and doing dangle
CCAP this kind of just naturally
happen so these are all called like
Triads I guess uh you're switching which
hand has two objects in it which one has
one there was this guy
same idea of the
swap from index thumb but when I start
this start from here I swing in as I
pend them both out the
side
wow there's the pouette in between
this the idea of that um
this is butterfly
Trion where we're swinging
over and catching downward like kind of
bar clish with our
thumb into which hand has so if this
hand has two one
[Music]
hand drugs
on drugs so this pattern right here uh
we actually didn't talk about this in
class we should have be broken down into
a butterfly
dangle
swap so this trick right here can be
broken down into a forward spinning
static dangle thing but one po single
poy in Reverse so this
butterfly reach over
swap it's almost like you're hitting an
atomic for a
second and nope 36
mafia thumb middle
pinky thumb native shoulder start my
Superman after the first two bounces of
the Fantastic 4 so we have Outside
Inside once both po are down I'm going
to go from right shoulder swing across
to the opposite shoulder continue my
fantastic FL same going
back variation of this is this weird
extension
thing wait one
more weird extension thing
back in damnn it one more one more this
for real weird extension
thing back in to
Superman maybe one more time I don't
[Music]
know yep and now was spinning three D
Point same Dam time at flame Festival
1997 Chris Kelly 1997 that's my last
class flame f
blame
Festival
1997 I'd rather
it